2020 is the 100th anniversary of women winning the right to vote in the United States, yet full equality for women in this country remains elusive. Yes, U.S. Senator Kamala Harris is the Democratic nominee for vice president, which is certainly significant. Yet she's only the second black woman ever to be elected to the U.S. Senate, which has only seen 57 female members since the dawn of our country. Only one quarter of the Senate is female today, while the much larger House, with 435 members, is 235 members, is 23,
2020年是美国女性获得投票权100周年，然而在这个国家，女性实现完全平等仍然遥不可及。是的，美国参议员卡玛拉·哈里斯（Kamala Harris）是民主党的副总统候选人，这当然意义重大。然而，她只是美国历史上第二位当选为美国参议员的黑人女性，而自建国以来，参议院总共只有57名女性成员。如今，参议院中只有四分之一是女性，而规模大得多的众议院共有435名成员，其中235名成员，是23，
percent female. The number of women at the top of the business world is also scant. We have just reached an all-time high of 37 women CEOs of the Fortune 500, but that means that almost 93% of those top companies are led by men. Why has it taken so many years for women to make even these gains? What are the particular challenges faced by women who strive to be leaders? How can psychology help us better understand the factors that hold women back or push them down, or discourage them from aiming for the top. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Alice Eggley, a professor of psychology at Northwestern
百分之二十三是女性。商业界高层的女性人数也寥寥无几。我们刚刚达到了财富500强中女性首席执行官人数的历史最高点——37人，但这也就意味着这些顶级公司中近93%仍由男性领导。为什么女性花了这么多年才取得这些进展？那些努力成为领导者的女性面临着哪些特殊的挑战？心理学如何能帮助我们更好地理解那些阻碍女性、打压女性，或使她们不敢向高层迈进的因素？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是西北大学心理学教授爱丽丝·伊格利（Dr. Alice Eagly）博士，
University who for many years has studied the psychology of gender, especially sex differences and similarities in leadership, pro-social behavior, aggression, partner preferences, and political attitudes. Dr. Egli has written numerous articles, chapters, and books on these topics. Her most recent book, Through the Labyrinth, The Truth About How Women Become Leaders, challenges the common metaphor of the glass ceiling. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Egli. I'm pleased to be here, Kim. This is not the first time a woman has been on the vice presidential ticket in this country, and women have run for president, although only once as a major party candidate.
她多年来一直研究性别心理学，特别是领导力、亲社会行为、攻击性、伴侣偏好和政治态度方面的性别差异与相似之处。伊格利博士就这些主题撰写了大量的文章、章节和书籍。她最近的著作《穿越迷宫：女性如何成为领导者的真相》（Through the Labyrinth: The Truth About How Women Become Leaders）挑战了“玻璃天花板”这一常见的隐喻。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，伊格利博士。很高兴来到这里，金。这并不是美国历史上第一次有女性出现在副总统候选人名单上，女性也曾竞选过总统，尽管作为主要政党候选人只有一次。
Is there something different about what's happening now and are the reactions from the media and the public different this time around? Well, yes. I think that it was entirely expected, even demanded of a Democratic candidate, such as Joe Biden, because the support for the Democratic Party is stronger among women than men. So it really called for women being represented. And then it's a time when there's a good deal of protest and, unrest over minority issues.
现在发生的事情有什么不同吗？媒体和公众的反应这次有什么不同吗？嗯，是的。我认为这对于像乔·拜登（Joe Biden）这样的民主党候选人来说是完全预料之中的，甚至是必须的，因为民主党在女性中的支持率高于男性。所以这确实需要女性代表。而且现在正值人们对少数群体问题有大量抗议和动荡的时期。
And so choosing a woman of color certainly made sense to represent that community, which tends to lean Democratic, but to, you know, to call on their loyalty in this particular way. So I think it was entirely expected and generally very well received. Yeah, that's been interesting that there has not been a whole lot of backlash, I think. No. I mean, what are the characteristics that make her less of a target? She is quite qualified in the sense that she had a number of political roles in California, and she is a senator.
因此，选择一位有色人种女性来代表那个倾向于支持民主党的群体确实很有意义，你知道，这是一种以这种特殊方式呼吁她们忠诚的做法。所以我认为这是完全预料之中的，而且总体上非常受欢迎。是的，有趣的是，我认为并没有出现太多的强烈反对。没有。我的意思是，是什么特征使她受到的攻击较少？她在某种意义上非常有资格，因为她在加利福尼亚州担任过多个政治职务，而且她是一位参议员。
And so she has very good qualifications that would be normal in a male candidate. So she's qualified in that sense. she's also quite gifted as a speaker and a debater, as was displayed earlier in the hearings in the Senate. So I think she struck the public as, you know, somebody who had the toughness to be a good campaigner. So what particular challenges do women politicians face first as candidates and then once they're elected? Well, there are serious challenges that are embedded in the culture, in a sense, in terms of the way we think about leaders and the way we think about women and men. So this is well established in studies on stereotyping done by psychologists and political scientists in this case. So we know that people think women are the nicer, kind, or more compassionate sex, more sympathetic to elements.
所以她具备男性候选人通常会有的非常好的资历。从这个意义上说，她是合格的。她作为演讲者和辩论者也非常有天赋，正如早些时候在参议院听证会上所展示的那样。所以我认为她给公众留下的印象是，你知道，一个有韧性成为一名优秀竞选者的人。那么，女性政治家首先作为候选人，然后一旦当选，会面临哪些特殊的挑战呢？嗯，在某种意义上，这些挑战深深植根于文化之中，体现在我们思考领导者的方式以及我们思考女性和男性的方式上。这一点在心理学家和政治学家所做的刻板印象研究中已经得到了很好的证实。所以我们知道，人们认为女性是更友善、更和蔼或更富有同情心的性别，对
others, better social skills, and the tougher, more agentic, we call it, more assertive, more aggressive sex. Okay, we know about that. But then people think about leaders as more agentic than communal. So they think about, you know, they have to take charge, they have to be tough, tell people what to do often. So that image is widely shared in the culture and is much more similar to men than women. So that puts women at something of a disadvantage.
他人更具同情心，社交能力更强；而男性是更强硬、更具代理性（我们称之为agentic）、更果断、更具攻击性的性别。好的，我们知道这一点。但人们又认为领导者比女性更具代理性，而不是更具公共性。所以他们认为，你知道，他们必须掌控全局，他们必须强硬，经常告诉别人该做什么。因此，这种形象在文化中被广泛认同，而且与男性的形象比女性更相似。这使女性处于某种劣势。
And it sort of goes like that. Well, she's, you know, she's very nice. But then the butt is, you know, I don't know if she's tough enough to handle that kind of situation. Could she really hold up in a big debate, you know? Could she get people to do things? Which she have the respect and authority. And so that lingers in the culture. And so women have to overcome, in a sense, these anxieties people have.
情况往往是这样的：嗯，她，你知道，她人很好。但随之而来的“但是”是，你知道，我不知道她是否足够强硬来处理那种情况。她真的能在大型辩论中坚持住吗？你知道，她能让人们去做事吗？她会有威望和权威吗？这种想法在文化中挥之不去。因此，女性在某种意义上必须克服人们的这些焦虑。
It's not about being a good person or a competent person. It's about being a tough enough person to really take on that kind of role that demands a lot of competition and assertion. And yet, if you're too, tough as a woman, then that cuts against you as well. That's right. That's the agency paradox. So, if you're very assertive, like, so you say, well, okay, I'll be just like a man. Wrong. That doesn't really work for women. Unless, you know, it could take on qualities of being assertive to some extent, but not to go to the extremes as dangerous, but add to it the qualities of warmth and kindness and empathy.
这与是否是一个好人或有能力的人无关。这关乎是否足够强硬，能够真正承担起那种需要大量竞争和主张的角色。然而，如果你作为一个女性太强硬，那也会对你不利。没错。这就是“代理悖论”。所以，如果你非常果断，比如你说，好吧，我会像个男人一样。错了。这对女性来说并不奏效。除非，你知道，可以在某种程度上具备果断的品质，但不要走向极端，那很危险，还要加上温暖、善良和同理心的品质。
So display both. That tends to be something that works for women who are leaders or wish to be leaders. And you can see that in Kamala Harris right away. She speaks in a clear, pleasantly assertive way. she smiles a lot too and has a lot of feminine expressiveness in her gestures and voice. Not too much, but it's definitely there.
所以要两者兼顾。这往往对那些已经是领导者或希望成为领导者的女性有效。你可以立刻在卡玛拉·哈里斯身上看到这一点。她说话清晰、令人愉快且果断。她也经常微笑，在手势和声音中有很多女性化的表达。不是太多，但绝对存在。
And so I think she has that blend that, in fact, works very well for women in leadership roles. You recently published a study that looked at a large body of nationally representative public opinion polling and found that women are now perceived as being just as competent as men as well as more communal, but they're seen as less ambitious. How have these views changed over the past decades?
所以我认为她拥有那种实际上对担任领导职务的女性非常有效的融合特质。你最近发表了一项研究，审视了大量具有全国代表性的公众舆论调查，发现女性现在被认为与男性一样有能力，而且更具公共性，但她们被认为野心较小。这些观点在过去几十年里发生了怎样的变化？
Is this good news for women leaders today? It's mixed news. So this study was based on representative public opinion poll data where people were asked about men and women. And the data go back to 1946 and then through 2018. So it's quite a nice series. And so the way the pollsters do this is they ask a very direct question. They say like intelligence, more true of women, more true of men, or equally true. And so we do see a lot of change in that women's competence relative to men has risen.
这对今天的女性领导者来说是好消息吗？这是喜忧参半的消息。这项研究基于具有代表性的民意调查数据，人们被问及关于男性和女性的问题。数据可以追溯到1946年，一直到2018年。所以这是一个非常好的系列。民意调查人员这样做的方式是提出一个非常直接的问题。他们会问，比如智力，是女性更具备，男性更具备，还是同样具备。我们确实看到了很多变化，女性相对于男性的能力有所提升。
So most Americans now say equal. But those who don't say equal are more likely to say women than men. So there. Competence leans slightly in the female direction. So that would be like being intelligent. The other change is rather unexpected to many observers, I think, or social scientists in particular, that the communion of women versus men has increased. So now it's overwhelmingly true, if you say something like sympathetic, more true of women or men.
所以大多数美国人现在说“平等”。但那些不说“平等”的人，认为女性比男性更具备能力的比例更高。所以，能力稍微向女性倾斜。这就像是聪明才智。另一个变化对许多观察家，特别是社会科学家来说是相当出乎意料的，那就是女性相对于男性的公共性增加了。所以现在，如果你问类似“富有同情心”的问题，是女性还是男性更具备，答案绝大多数是女性。
It's women. So that has changed over time to be more extreme. And agency doesn't change. So 1946 people saw men as more aggressive and assertive than women. And they still do, and there's no significant change in that trend. So for women not to be troubled by these stereotypes, it's the agency that has to change as well as the competence. People have to see women as tough enough, and that still goes in the male direction. The competence is very helpful, you know, if anything, you know, women are somewhat more competent than men, because competence is a, you know, something people expect of leaders.
是女性。所以这一点随着时间的推移变得更加极端。而代理性并没有改变。所以1946年人们认为男性比女性更具攻击性和果断。他们现在仍然这样认为，这一趋势没有显著变化。因此，女性要摆脱这些刻板印象，不仅能力需要改变，代理性也需要改变。人们必须认为女性足够强硬，而这一点仍然向男性倾斜。能力非常有帮助，你知道，如果说有什么不同的话，女性在某种程度上比男性更有能力，因为能力是人们对领导者的期望。
And the communion is probably not particularly effective in terms of being seen as even more communal than women in the past. Well, what do you think is different in other countries? I mean, women are still underrepresented in leadership in America, but other industrialized countries have been led by women. You can think of Germany or England or even New Zealand today. What's different there? The political scientists explain that women have better chances at a parliamentary system than a presidential system. So in a parliamentary system, you know, the executive and the legislative branches are combined because the prime minister is the head of the party that wins.
而公共性在被视为比过去更具公共性方面可能并不是特别有效。那么，你认为其他国家有什么不同？我的意思是，女性在美国的领导层中仍然代表性不足，但其他工业化国家已经由女性领导。你可以想到今天的德国、英国甚至新西兰。那里有什么不同？政治学家解释说，女性在议会制国家比在总统制国家有更好的机会。在议会制国家，你知道，行政和立法部门是结合在一起的，因为总理是获胜政党的领袖。
It has the majority. And so women can make their way up through good service and popularity in their own districts up the hierarchy in the party, you know, like Margaret Thatcher and a couple of others, and you can make it to the top of your party, and then, by the way, you get to be prime minister if your party is elected. They don't elect a person directly. They elect a party. But we don't have that.
它拥有多数席位。所以女性可以通过在自己选区良好的服务和受欢迎程度，在党内层级中晋升，你知道，就像玛格丽特·撒切尔（Margaret Thatcher）和其他几个人一样，你可以进入党内高层，然后，顺便说一句，如果你的政党当选，你就能成为总理。他们不是直接选举一个人。他们选举一个政党。但我们没有那样。
We have the separate executive. And so the focus is all on this one role. And, you know, being a woman or a man, you're voting for the person. And I think that brings out the difficulties that women have even in the UK, because they're never voted for as a person when they get to be prime minister. And then the other thing, in some countries, and it happened a little bit here as an attempt, you know, there's a passing on through family, very elite family ties. And so Indira Gandhi was Nero's daughter. Right. And so some countries have that passing on.
我们有独立的行政部门。所以焦点全在这个单一的角色上。而且，你知道，作为一个女性或男性，你是在为这个人投票。我认为这带来了女性即使在英国也面临的困难，因为当她们成为总理时，她们从来不是作为一个人被投票选出的。还有一件事，在一些国家，这里也发生过一点尝试，你知道，通过家庭传承，非常精英的家庭纽带。所以英迪拉·甘地（Indira Gandhi）是尼赫鲁（Nehru）的女儿。没错。所以一些国家有那种传承。
And if there's not a male to pass it on to it, it might get passed on to a wife in some cases or, you know, to a child. Of course, we had a hint of that with the Clintons, didn't we? Almost. But it didn't. go and all was said and done. But it's not a tradition in the U.S. to do that. Exactly. There was the two bushes, so it looked like we did it, though.
如果没有男性可以传承，在某些情况下可能会传给妻子，或者，你知道，传给孩子。当然，我们在克林顿夫妇身上看到了这一点，不是吗？几乎。但它没有成功，一切都结束了。但这在美国并不是一种传统。确实。有两个布什，所以看起来我们做到了，尽管如此。
But anyway, it's a stronger tradition in some other countries where it's happened at an earlier point, you know, as when Indira Gandhi was Prime Minister of India. So there are differences in the governmental system. There may be differences in attitudes, too, but it's particularly the structure of the political system, I think. I mean, we would tend to see some of those cultures as being even more sexish than the United States. Yes, yes.
但无论如何，在一些更早发生这种情况的国家，这是一种更强的传统，你知道，就像英迪拉·甘地担任印度总理时那样。所以政府体制存在差异。态度可能也存在差异，但我认为主要是政治体制的结构。我的意思是，我们倾向于认为其中一些文化比美国更性别歧视。是的，是的。
But yet, like Pakistan and India and other countries have had. Right, Benazir Budo, yeah, same situation. Yeah, have had women. And they tend to have been closely aligned in the narrow elites that were in the, you know, often by blood. So in your book through the labyrinth, you challenge the notion of the glass ceiling, that solid but somewhat invisible barrier that most of us think women face when it comes to reaching the highest echelons of leadership. Why do you think that metaphor is not apt and that a labyrinth is closer to the challenges that women face? Well, there's a couple of reasons at least. One is it suggests a very solid barrier.
但像巴基斯坦、印度和其他国家却有过。没错，贝娜齐尔·布托（Benazir Bhutto），是的，同样的情况。是的，有过女性领导人。而且她们往往与狭隘的精英阶层紧密结盟，你知道，通常是血缘关系。在你的书《穿越迷宫》中，你挑战了“玻璃天花板”的概念，即我们大多数人认为女性在达到最高领导层时面临的那种坚固但有些隐形的障碍。为什么你认为这个隐喻不恰当，而“迷宫”更接近女性面临的挑战？嗯，至少有几个原因。首先，它暗示了一个非常坚固的障碍。
And I don't think it's like prejudices aren't like that. They are more fungible and malleable. And it isn't that we've never had women as, for instance, CEOs in the Fortune 500. So there are some and have been others. But the other reason, it suggests that the barrier is right near the top, right? So you move up through your career and, oh, my God, you can't. be CEO because there's this barrier at the top, next to the top. But that's not how it works in terms of careers in management or other areas that involve leadership. The challenges are
我不认为偏见是那样的。它们更具可变性和可塑性。并不是说我们从未有过女性担任财富500强公司的首席执行官。所以有一些，也曾经有过其他人。但另一个原因是，它暗示障碍就在顶端附近，对吧？所以你在职业生涯中向上攀升，然后，天哪，你不能成为首席执行官，因为顶端有这个障碍。但管理或其他涉及领导力的领域的职业生涯并不是这样运作的。挑战是
all along the way. It's in day one. You go to work as a, you know, a manager just coming in with your MBA. The challenges you have as a woman are there and they're there every day. And As you rise, there are different challenges, you know, it goes on and on. So it isn't as if you're exactly the same as men, and then near the top there's a glass ceiling. It's really a completely wrong metaphor. You know, it has some truth to it, perhaps, but it doesn't adequately represent the nature of the challenges, which are all along the way. And so that's why we propose labyrinth, that the man has a relatively straight road. You know, maybe he has some bumps along the way or whatever.
一路走来都有。从第一天开始。你作为一名刚拿到MBA学位的经理去工作。你作为女性面临的挑战就在那里，而且每天都在那里。随着你的晋升，会有不同的挑战，你知道，它没完没了。所以并不是说你和男性完全一样，然后在顶端附近有一个玻璃天花板。这真的是一个完全错误的隐喻。你知道，它可能有一些道理，但它不能充分代表挑战的本质，这些挑战是贯穿始终的。这就是为什么我们提出“迷宫”，男人有一条相对笔直的道路。你知道，也许他一路上有一些颠簸之类的。
But the woman has to go through this labyrinth. So she has to be smarter, right? And she has to figure out how to overcome these challenges that she might face as a woman. She might take a wrong turn, but, you know, it's possible to turn around and go on, you know. if you're really persistent, but you've got to expect you might get confused at some time and, you know, take a wrong term. So it more represents the true complexity of women's careers in leadership than a glass ceiling does. You published a meta-analysis in 2011 that examined the extent to which stereotypes of leaders are culturally masculine. Can you talk about those findings and whether these stereotypes have changed in the intervening years?
但女性必须穿过这个迷宫。所以她必须更聪明，对吧？她必须弄清楚如何克服她作为女性可能面临的这些挑战。她可能会走错路，但是，你知道，如果真的很坚持，是有可能转过身继续前进的，但你必须预料到你可能会在某个时候感到困惑，你知道，走错路。所以它比玻璃天花板更能代表女性在领导力方面职业生涯的真正复杂性。你在2011年发表了一项荟萃分析，考察了领导者刻板印象在多大程度上是文化上男性化的。你能谈谈这些发现以及这些刻板印象在随后的几年里是否发生了变化吗？
Right. We did publish a meta-analysis. It involved actually three underlying types of studies that had looked at the leader stereotype. The most famous paradigm was started by Virgin Shine, and it's called the Think Manager, Think Male paradigm. It started first in 1973. And in that study, there are three groups of participants. One rates women, one rates men. and one rates managers or leaders. And they do it on a long list of traits.
好的。我们确实发表了一项荟萃分析。它实际上涉及了三种研究领导者刻板印象的基础研究类型。最著名的范式是由弗吉尼亚·沙因（Virginia Schein）发起的，被称为“想到经理，想到男性”（Think Manager, Think Male）范式。它始于1973年。在那项研究中，有三组参与者。一组评价女性，一组评价男性，一组评价经理或领导者。他们在一长串特质上进行评价。
And then they correlate these ratings, the men group to the leader group and the woman group to the leader group. And they find the male leader correlations are much higher than the woman leader correlations, which is just what we said before. People think that leaders are, you know, masculine and assertive.
然后他们将这些评分进行相关性分析，男性组与领导者组的相关性，以及女性组与领导者组的相关性。他们发现男性领导者的相关性远高于女性领导者的相关性，这正是我们之前所说的。人们认为领导者是，你知道，男性化和果断的。
And some men are more like leaders than women are. And so that's why I got called the think manager think male paradigm. And so it started in 1973 so we could look at it over many years. And we did find some shift. And that was the woman leader's relationship. There was some gain in thinking that leaders had more feminine characteristics, that is, in particular more social skills. So the notion of leader had changed so that, yes, people continued to think that leaders need to be tough and assertive, but by the way, they should be somewhat socially skilled.
而且有些男性比女性更像领导者。这就是为什么它被称为“想到经理，想到男性”范式。它始于1973年，所以我们可以观察它多年来的变化。我们确实发现了一些转变。那就是女性领导者的关系。在认为领导者具有更多女性特征，即特别是更多社交技能方面，有一些增长。所以领导者的概念已经改变了，是的，人们继续认为领导者需要强硬和果断，但顺便说一句，他们应该具备一定的社交技能。
And so it was a hint of androgyny coming in, but still the masculine characteristics won out over the feminine, even in the most recent study. So it was a shift that would be welcoming to women, this growth of adrogyny, but it didn't go all the way to androgyny. It just was some addition of the social skills, sympathy, empathy kind of thing to what people expect for leaders. You've also looked at differences in pro-social behaviors between men and women. How are they different and how are they the same? Pro-social behavior, you know, encompasses a lot of different kinds of behaviors. And so we found that both sexes engage in pro-social behavior, a lot of it. So they're similar engaging in this class of behaviors, but they tend to specialize to some extent in different aspects.
所以这是一种双性化（androgyny）出现的迹象，但即使在最近的研究中，男性特征仍然胜过女性特征。所以这是一个对女性友好的转变，这种双性化的增长，但它并没有完全达到双性化。它只是在人们对领导者的期望中增加了一些社交技能、同情心、共情之类的东西。你也研究了男性和女性在亲社会行为上的差异。它们有何不同，又有何相同之处？亲社会行为，你知道，涵盖了许多不同种类的行为。我们发现两性都参与亲社会行为，而且很多。所以他们在参与这类行为方面是相似的，但他们在不同方面往往有一定程度的专业化。
And one of the things we were interested in, in particular, was pro-social behavior where the helper puts him or herself at some risk. And that was interesting because there was a lot of differentiation. So men are more likely to do physically dangerous acts to save other people's lives, such as saving somebody from drowning, running into a burning building and pulling out somebody, intervening in a crime setting where the criminal has a gun. so these are truly life-threatening and although women sometimes do these things it's considerably less likely but another thing that has some danger is living kitten donation
我们特别感兴趣的一件事是，帮助者将自己置于某种风险中的亲社会行为。这很有趣，因为有很多差异。男性更有可能为了拯救他人的生命而做出身体上危险的行为，例如从溺水中救人、冲进燃烧的建筑物救出某人、在罪犯有枪的犯罪现场进行干预。这些确实是危及生命的，虽然女性有时也会做这些事情，但可能性要小得多。但另一件有一定危险的事情是活体肾脏捐赠，
you know giving your kidney you're a perfectly healthy person and this person's kidneys have given out and would you jump up and say well you can have mine that's not an easy decision because it involves not actually a lot of risk but it involves an operation and some some real risk to your health and whatever and we find women are more likely to do that it's to give parts of their body it's often done in family it's within families because the more you're genetically matched, you know, the safer it is for the person who receives it. But women are more likely to, and highly disproportion for giving to a spouse, women are much more likely to give to a husband than husband is to a wife. That's pretty amazing. So there's a dangerous
你知道，捐出你的肾脏，你是一个完全健康的人，而这个人的肾脏衰竭了，你会跳出来说，好吧，你可以用我的吗？这不是一个容易的决定，因为它涉及的不仅仅是风险，它涉及手术和对你健康的一些真正风险等等。我们发现女性更有可能这样做，即捐献身体部位。这通常是在家庭中完成的，因为基因匹配度越高，你知道，对接受者来说就越安全。但女性更有可能这样做，而且在捐献给配偶方面比例极高，女性捐献给丈夫的可能性远高于丈夫捐献给妻子。这太令人惊奇了。所以有一种危险的
kind of helping behavior, but it's somewhat female dominated. So other calls, other You know, volunteer organizations, such as doctors and nurses who go into dangerous situations and that kind of thing. Women are very well represented in those kinds of organizations, even though they're so brisk. Of course, there's a higher proportion of women nurses. Yeah, but both nurses and doctors and even psychologists are needed in those situations. because they're traumatic. Sure. So another thing we looked at,
帮助行为，但它在某种程度上是女性主导的。所以其他呼吁，其他你知道，志愿者组织，例如进入危险情况的医生和护士等等。女性在这些组织中代表性非常好，尽管它们风险很高。当然，女性护士的比例更高。是的，但在这些情况下也需要护士、医生甚至心理学家。因为它们是创伤性的。当然。所以我们看的另一件事，
it took quite a lot of time to gather all the available data, was Holocaust rescuing by non-Jewish persons, which happened in the occupied countries of Europe. And there were records. They're actually kept by Yad Vashem, which is an organization in Israel. And they are held at the Holocaust Museum in Washington, from which we got the records, from which we could classify the people by nationality and sex. And we found women slightly overrepresented.
花了相当多的时间收集所有可用的数据，是非犹太人进行的犹太人大屠杀营救，这发生在欧洲被占领的国家。有记录。它们实际上是由以色列的亚德瓦谢姆（Yad Vashem）组织保存的。它们保存在华盛顿的大屠杀博物馆，我们从那里获得了记录，从中我们可以按国籍和性别对这些人进行分类。我们发现女性略微超额代表。
Often you couldn't tell because it was a couple, you know, but then when there was individuals recognized for having represented. There was a slight over-representation of women. And this was extremely dangerous, particularly in Poland. The rescuers were just sent to the camps, or even killed, right away. So it was a very dangerous act. So what did we think? We thought as an overall description that women tended to be overrepresented when there was a very deeply relational kind of act as giving your kidney to another person. That's very deeply
通常你无法分辨，因为那是一对夫妇，你知道，但当个人因代表性而受到认可时。女性有轻微的超额代表。这极其危险，特别是在波兰。营救者直接被送往集中营，甚至被杀害，对吧？所以这是一个非常危险的行为。那么我们怎么想呢？我们认为作为一个整体描述，当涉及到非常深层的关系行为时，女性往往会超额代表，比如把你的肾脏捐给另一个人。那是非常深层的
relational. And the Holocaust rescuing often was too because, you know, it would be a co-worker or a knock on the door and you had to let people into your house and hide, you know, in the Anne Frank case to hide them. So this was very deeply relational. And so the women were somewhat overrepresented when the helping was of this type. And men were more overrepresented when the act demanded, often physical strength, of course, and some sudden action of rescue in a dangerous situation and stranger rescue. You know, the person that's out there drowning is often not in your family. But you know, you're at the beach and it becomes apparent.
关系。大屠杀营救通常也是如此，因为，你知道，那可能是同事，或者敲门声，你必须让人们进入你的房子并隐藏，你知道，在安妮·弗兰克（Anne Frank）的案例中隐藏他们。所以这非常深层地具有关系性。因此，当帮助是这种类型时，女性在某种程度上被超额代表。而当行为需要，通常是体力，当然，以及在危险情况下的某种突然营救行动和陌生人营救时，男性被超额代表。你知道，那个在外面溺水的人通常不在你的家庭里。但你知道，你在海滩上，它变得显而易见。
So that kind of stranger rescuing, demanding the very sudden decision, and often there was a, you know, could be a physical element in strength being an advantage that men are overrepresented. So there was some gendering on all of this. Yeah, but it makes sense. I mean, especially if, I mean, a woman may say, oh, I'd like to run into that burning building and save those children, but I don't think I can, I could physically do it. Yeah, you're not sure you could be a man or a grown person in there. And you couldn't. And they are trained, of course, but firefighters. But ordinary people sometimes do those things, too, you know, not just the firefighter.
所以那种陌生人营救，需要非常突然的决定，而且通常有，你知道，体力优势可能是一个因素，男性在这些方面被超额代表。所以这一切都有一些性别化。是的，但这说得通。我的意思是，特别是如果，我的意思是，一个女性可能会说，哦，我想冲进那栋燃烧的建筑物救那些孩子，但我认为我不能，我身体上做不到。是的，你不确定你能成为那里的男人或成年人。你做不到。当然，他们受过训练，消防员。但普通人有时也会做那些事情，你知道，不仅仅是消防员。
Sure. Well, let's step back for a minute and look at the big picture, because you've spent your career looking at differences and similarities between men and women. And during those years, there have been a lot of cultural changes. There are more women in the workforce today. men are beginning to question the societal expectations for them to be tough and aggressive. The Me Too movement has rendered some behaviors unacceptable. Are men and women, do you think, changing intrinsically through these upheavals? Are the differences narrowing between what American society considers masculine and what it considers feminine?
当然。好吧，让我们退后一步，看看大局，因为你职业生涯都在研究男性和女性之间的差异和相似之处。在这些年里，发生了很多文化变革。今天劳动力市场上有更多的女性。男性开始质疑社会对他们强硬和好斗的期望。Me Too运动使一些行为变得不可接受。你认为男性和女性是否正在通过这些剧变在本质上发生改变？美国社会认为的男性化和女性化之间的差异是否正在缩小？
Wow, that is a very big question. certainly women have changed profoundly by most women moving into the labor force into a whole range of roles so women have had to their lives have changed but if you look at that labor force it's pretty segregated so women tend to be in roles that are communally demanding nursing and teaching and social work, all women are overrepresented. You can say, well, yeah, but what about those other roles they've gone into? Like their lawyers and doctors, too, aren't they? Yes.
哇，那是一个非常大的问题。当然，大多数女性进入劳动力市场，进入各种各样的角色，她们的生活发生了深刻的变化。但如果你看看那个劳动力市场，它是相当隔离的。所以女性倾向于从事对公共性要求很高的角色，护理、教学和社会工作，所有这些女性都超额代表。你可以说，好吧，是的，但她们进入的其他那些角色呢？比如她们也是律师和医生，不是吗？是的。
But then there's an internal segregation. So look at public interest law. You'll see a whole lot of women and family law, a whole lot of women. And you look at medicine. it's obvious which specialty is most female-dominated. Pediatrics. And, of course, gynecology and psychiatry. There are a lot of women.
但内部存在隔离。所以看看公益法律。你会看到很多女性和家庭法，很多女性。看看医学。很明显哪个专业女性主导程度最高。儿科。当然，还有妇科和精神病学。有很多女性。
So, again, in the more communally demanding areas, and in management, in business, you could also guess which areas most female-dominated. human resources and public relations, which demands, you know, the social skill to go out there and represent your country. So there's, at some deep level of communion and agency, there's less change than people perhaps think because of the segregation not only between occupations, but within occupations at the kinds of sub-specialties, the women versus the men take on. So, yes, there's been enormous change.
所以，同样，在公共性要求更高的领域，以及在管理、商业领域，你也可以猜到哪个领域女性主导程度最高。人力资源和公共关系，这需要，你知道，走出去代表你的国家的社交技能。所以，在某种深层的公共性和代理性层面上，变化比人们想象的要少，因为不仅职业之间存在隔离，而且在职业内部，女性与男性所承担的子专业类型也存在隔离。所以，是的，发生了巨大的变化。
And we see in the stereotypes what's certainly ought to be there, which is the rise of women's communion. Because after all women are more educated now, you know, the men, many more college degrees. And even the Ph.D. goes slightly in the female direction now. So there's an enormous change in a kind of education, therefore, which produces knowledge and competence of that type. And so that's an enormous change of women becoming like men in that sense, but overtaking them. So that's fantastic. But there's this underlying agency of communion, the Yid and Yang dynamic, that we still see in the data. And so we don't know what exactly that comes from.
我们在刻板印象中看到了肯定应该存在的东西，那就是女性公共性的兴起。因为毕竟女性现在受教育程度更高了，你知道，男性，更多的大学学位。甚至博士学位现在也稍微向女性倾斜。所以教育方面发生了巨大的变化，因此产生了那种知识和能力。所以这是女性在那种意义上变得像男性，甚至超越他们的巨大变化。所以这太棒了。但存在这种潜在的代理性与公共性的阴阳动态，我们在数据中仍然看到。所以我们不知道这到底来自哪里。
You know, there's the nature-nurture question there. Right. So do you have any words of wisdom for those American women who are hoping someday to be president or CEO of a Fortune 500 company? What can they do in our current culture to improve their odds of success? Well, one thing we see, particularly in politics, in running for office, the women are more qualified in the sense they have more past experience in education that's relevant to the job. They become overqualified in terms of those kinds of criteria. I'm not sure the extent to which that's true in business, but I wouldn't be surprised. So the idea would be don't skip on the qualifications.
你知道，那里有先天与后天的问题。没错。那么，对于那些希望有一天能成为总统或财富500强公司首席执行官的美国女性，你有什么智慧之言吗？在当前的文化中，她们能做些什么来提高成功的几率？嗯，我们看到的一件事，特别是在政治领域，在竞选公职时，女性在某种意义上更有资格，因为她们在与工作相关的教育方面有更多的过往经验。她们在这些标准方面变得过度合格。我不确定这在商业领域在多大程度上是真的，但我不会感到惊讶。所以这个想法是，不要在资历上偷工减料。
If most of those people have MBAs, get one and get one from the best place you can get one from. And then if you want to go into politics, okay, when you're young, you've got to get started. When you're in college, go to the Republican or Democratic society for the students and try to get into leadership roles. and then volunteer for campaigns. You know, get the knowledge, get the contacts. Because they're probably going to be more important in general for the woman than the man. We find that in politics it's harder for women to get the support and money for the campaign than it is for men. So you've got to get well-networked to compete.
如果大多数人都有MBA学位，那就去拿一个，而且要从你能拿到的最好的地方拿。然后如果你想进入政界，好吧，当你年轻的时候，你必须开始。当你上大学时，去参加学生的共和党或民主党协会，并尝试进入领导角色。然后为竞选活动做志愿者。你知道，获取知识，建立联系。因为它们对女性来说通常比对男性更重要。我们发现，在政治中，女性比男性更难获得竞选的支持和资金。所以你必须建立良好的网络来竞争。
so the root may be a little harder therefore you have to bring more to bear so don't skimp on it don't think you could skimp on it so to get in there and get the kind of background that's as ideal as possible so that's very important and then
所以这条路可能更难，因此你必须付出更多，所以不要偷工减料，不要认为你可以偷工减料。所以要进入那里，获得尽可能理想的背景，这非常重要。然后
you do need to keep in mind the double mind this is what we talked about before but another name is the double bind that as a woman you're expected to be communal to be kind and caring and you know nice and as a man you're as a as a leader rather you're expected to be able to take charge and to be assertive and you know to be able to argue with people and hold your own um so there's both of those things the men can just do the latter you know but the woman have to to be successful, ordinarily have to bring the communion along. Because it's very important for them to be liked.
你确实需要记住“双重束缚”（double bind），这就是我们之前谈到的，但另一个名字是双重束缚，即作为女性，你被期望具有公共性，要善良、关怀，你知道，友善；而作为男性，或者说作为领导者，你被期望能够掌控全局，要果断，你知道，要能够与人争论并坚持自己的立场。所以这两者都有。男性可以只做后者，你知道，但女性要成功，通常必须同时具备公共性。因为被喜欢对她们来说非常重要。
Men can get away often with not being so liked. But the woman, if she's disliked, it's, you know, I think that was part of Hillary Clinton's problem. A lot of people disliked Trump, but a lot of people disliked Hillary. And I think that was a worse, that was more of a disadvantage for it. her because she's a woman. Yeah. And so, you know, to keep in mind the double bind and that you will have to negotiate it. And there's smart ways to do it.
男性通常可以因为不那么被喜欢而逃脱惩罚。但女性，如果她不被喜欢，你知道，我认为那是希拉里·克林顿（Hillary Clinton）问题的一部分。很多人不喜欢特朗普，但很多人不喜欢希拉里。我认为这对她来说是一个更糟糕的劣势，因为她是女性。是的。所以，你知道，要记住双重束缚，你将不得不去协商它。有聪明的方法可以做到。
I think Kamala Harris, insofar as I've seen her on television, is doing a good job with that. You know, so look at women who appear to be doing a good job as role models. Yeah, and then persistence. Because you're in that labyrinth, you mean. Take a wrong turn, don't give up. Yeah, don't give up, right. Yeah, just learned from it, you know, things go bad. In all charisma, many things I've done, I wish had gone better or I did something wrong, but, you know, I hung in there.
我认为卡玛拉·哈里斯，就我在电视上看到她的情况而言，在这方面做得很好。你知道，所以看看那些看起来做得很好的女性作为榜样。是的，然后是坚持。因为你在那个迷宫里，你知道。走错路，不要放弃。是的，不要放弃，对吧。是的，只是从中学习，你知道，事情变糟了。在我做过的所有事情中，我希望做得更好，或者我做错了什么，但是，你知道，我坚持了下来。
So that's important in all careers. but if you're in a career that has a labyrinth, then it's even more important. You know, you could get discouraged, but take a deep breath and learn from it and go on. Yeah, so I think, you know, I admire women who do make it through to these leadership roles. I think it took, because I think on the average it just takes more skill than it did for the man in leadership. ship, you know. He wouldn't be so much tested and questioned as to whether he could do the job. Sounds a little unfair, but I guess you just have to put up with that, right? It's unfair, but it's like you also have a burden for the people become, the women become
所以这在所有职业中都很重要。但如果你处于一个有迷宫的职业中，那就更重要了。你知道，你可能会感到气馁，但深呼吸，从中学习并继续前进。是的，所以我认为，你知道，我很钦佩那些确实进入这些领导角色的女性。我认为这需要，因为我认为平均而言，这比男性在领导力方面需要更多的技能。你知道。他不会受到那么多的考验和质疑，质疑他是否能胜任这份工作。听起来有点不公平，但我猜你只能忍受这一点，对吧？这不公平，但就像你也为后来的人承担负担一样，女性
come along later, you know. So we could be thankful for Hillary Clinton. Yeah. Yeah. That she was there and got people used to her. who shouldn't win, but she won the popular vote. Hey, come on now. So the women that come next, like Kamala Harris, I think, have an easier time because of her and other women in politics. So, yeah, so we have to think it's unfair, but it's not as unfair as it was earlier because they were there. and I hope to make it less unfair for the women who come next.
后来的人，你知道。所以我们应该感谢希拉里·克林顿。是的。是的。她曾经在那里，让人们习惯了她。谁不应该赢，但她赢得了普选票。嘿，拜托。所以接下来来的女性，比如卡玛拉·哈里斯，我认为，因为她和其他女性在政治中的存在，日子会好过一些。所以，是的，所以我们必须认为这不公平，但它不像以前那么不公平了，因为她们曾经在那里。我希望为接下来来的女性减少这种不公平。
That's a good way to look at it. Well, Dr. Agley, thank you so much for joining me today. This has been really interesting and just a very almost a fun conversation to have. Thank you, Kim. I enjoy talking with you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. Or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.
这是一个很好的看待方式。好吧，伊格利博士，非常感谢你今天加入我。这真的很有趣，几乎是一次有趣的谈话。谢谢你，金。我很喜欢和你交谈。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。或者在你获取播客的任何地方。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA。
That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Kondayan）。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。